[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous voulez toute façon une
petite démonstration pour commencer
correctement allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc je me présente enfin surtout
je vous présentais déjà la discipline ça
s'appelle tu paies mythe place dans
leurs beats c'est cet argent-là est
flatteur du coup c'est la discipline
donc en fait moi c'est vraiment au sol
je ne sers pas de module que vous avez
des bois il ya d'autres catégories comme
vous mais peut-être voir à la télévision
notamment en skate park ou en ville
du coup ils prennent des rampes qui font
des sauts et à la catégorie dirt où il
ya du coup des grosses bosses interne où
l'idéal points de vente saute dans la
vie faut un maximum de figures et
retombe et il ya la catégorie la plus
connue c'est la rescousse et la course
surveillent ok maintenant aux jeux
olympiques
voilà donc chaque catégorie à les
notions différentes chaque rider et
spécialisés moi je suis professionnel en
begins fans de faire peu du belize pâte
et voilà donc pour me représenter
rapidement je m'appelle telle manière
effectivement je suis dur brel nous
apperemment très plaisir d'être là pour
parler de ma passion et mon parcours
devant vous je suis professionnel depuis
maintenant deux ans donc c'est un peu
tout fait pour moi et ça fait 12 ans que
je fais du belize bat donc j'ai fait un
grand nombre de compétitions de
démonstration aussi dans différentes
catégories
j'ai gagné des compétitions à paris à
montpellier office notamment pour ceux
qui connaissent un peu disparu extrême
c'est aujourd'hui et du cic greffer
office et ça fait partie des
championnats du monde où j'avais des
17ème édition la en master juste avant
le thé brick road pour ça que je
pressens pro maintenant voilà donc j'ai
un parcours vraiment accès bel espace
est pourquoi je vous parle aujourd'hui
je suis pas vraiment le meilleur
en galice battus même loin d'être le
meilleur il ya des gens ne sont
champions du monde pour des grosses
marques que je peux pas citer et je fais
des choses je suis pas le meilleur
conférence et non plus parce que pour la
petite anecdote c'est la première
conférence pour moi j'ai l'habitude de
prendre micro pour des chaumes mais plus
en mode fait du bruit allait plus je
vais prendre vos oreilles aujourd'hui
donc voilà pourquoi nous choisir moi ce
que je fais c'est que je vous réponde à
cette question
un petit peu plus tard dans mon
explication je vais revenir un petit peu
sur mon parcours sur mes débuts et on a
déroulé le contenu et à la fin je
répondrais vous expliquer pourquoi je
suis là aujourd'hui
alors comme je vous disais j'ai commencé
en 2005 j'ai géré en bas de chez moi
j'étais avec un ami j'ai règne ci lui
avait eu des knicks vraiment bas de
gamme
à l'époque les vélos pesait six kilos là
il ya notre club et puis la différence
de potes et moi j'étais avec un vtt
mouvement vous et des dérapages de
cabrage vous à la course avec les
voitures
albert et donc je pense que des parents
dans la salle qui ont leurs enfants qui
préfèrent aux mélodies qui font des
dérapages échanges dopés semaine pour
rajouter dans ce cas là jusqu'à avoir un
petit déclic et j'espère qu'ils ont fort
mal pour une équipe possible et moi du
coup j'ai commencé avant ce déclic quand
je suis arrivé au skatepark de roanne
assez timide assez réservés on n'osait
pas trop aller voir les
des professionnels par les riders qui
étaient sur place on se disait peut-être
on me dira que l'on sait rien faire ne
vont pas nous donner des conseils
d'où pour rester dans notre point et on
est tombé sur un stickers sur ce sticker
sur cette eau produite au volant y avait
un site internet
on a les ressources internet et on avait
vu des explications sur comment choisir
un vélo les différentes catégories des
knicks comme je vous ai cités
précédemment et surtout des vidéos pour
commencer à faire du vélo donc y avait
tous niveaux y avait amateurs et alors
il ya peut-être tp gris amateurs experts
master et professionnels donc avait des
figures correspondait au niveau de
choisy et nous regarder ces figures lens
0 1
c'est incroyable comment on va réussir à
faire ça donc il y avait des vidéos pour
nous expliquer alors rapidement
merci à la famille aussi que nous à qui
nous a procuré de bmx pour commencer
donc on est allé sur parking concentré
tout le tout les journées à une période
thérèse yvan 35 40 heures par semaine
quand j'étais au lycée allende j'ai
étudié correctement j'ai fait mes études
mais parallèlement gtd que j'avais du
temps je faisais du bmx et je m'entraîne
et je m'entraîne et je m'écarte comme
sur les vidéos on a découvert que yahvé
youtube alors à l'époque en 2005
c'est pas si vieux que ça mais il ya
10-15 ans facebook
instagram tous les réseaux sociaux
n'était pas aussi développée que
maintenant on va peut être y avait
quelques vidéos mais elle était assez
rare on regardait toujours les mêmes
idéaux pour apprendre ensuite on s'est
dit bon ya des forums
à l'époque des pas vraiment les réseaux
sociaux c'était plus des profs on a pris
contact avec quelques riders et les anti
ben viens avec nous bien entraîné on est
avec des pros ont fait une session
c'était vergne ont concédé branlée nos
parents nous emmener vers lyon d'un
roulé avec des professionnels à l'époque
pour ces ivoires les quatre mêmes il
nous parle comme si on était dans
hamilton science est partie de leur
famille petit à petit je suis allé à
faire différent j'ai rencontré matthias
dandois qui est actuellement cinq fois
champion du monde qui est vraiment au
top
combes édition et ses parents pour
parler de lui mais c'est surtout pour
nous dire que voilà ce gala s'est
présenté me dis oh là tu as besoin de
conseils pour faire des figures pas
besoin de conseils pour avoir plus
d'expérience
pas de problème et du coup je me suis
dit là attend le champion du monde
c'est comme si en foot j'ai des
références mais zidane donner un conseil
des arts et des mains qui va jouer dans
le quartier j'ai trouvé ça incroyable
est vraiment c est ce qui m'a boosté
pourra vraiment prendre prendre les
devants et m informant minutes pour
ensuite comme tous les adolescents ont
regardé sur youtube sur youtube ont
envoyé des vidéos de bmx est lancée dit
moi aussi je veux montrer à nos nouveaux
copains de nouveaux collègues de bmx de
différentes régions de france
comment on va faire notre oeuvre
comment on apprend de nos figures
qu'elles sont de nouveaux tricks du coup
j'ai mis une modeste vidéo que j'avais
tourné sur le parking de la piscine
et puis à l'époque mettais ma vidéo là
et je m'en occupais plus alors vous
savez les notifications je recevais des
emails vous avez vendu commentaires pour
suivre le jeu mais j'en ai rien à
secouer
donc du coup j'ai tout enlevé les
notifications je ne me suis pas attardé
sur cette vidéo là et puis de temps en
temps je regardais jouer mule 5 mai lui
dis lui c'est correct
et puis il y avait d'autres riders qui
avait plusieurs millions de vues par les
bd vraiment professionnel sur des
grandes marques
après je me suis dit ok paris lui
cinquante minutes on a commencé à vous
proposer faire une pub sur ma vidéo de
changer la musique est demeuré mené là
pour ça il va c'était l'équivalent de 50
euros au lycée je me suis dit baye ou
pile je vais faire la fête
50 euros c'est mortel et après donc j'ai
changé la vidéo pour une moins bonne
alors désolé pour la vidéo ou la musique
que j'ai remplacé et a du coup c'est
monter ses montées bon pour la petite
anecdote
aujourd'hui il y avait plus de 800
millions j'ai parlé c'est à reproduire
ce
ce nombre de vues mais à l'époque j'en
ai mais enfin ce n'était pas mon ma
priorité
le nombre de vues les aigus sont très
contents mais ce qu'il ya dans la vidéo
les figures je propose c'est des vidéos
cd figurent amateurs un petit peu plus
mais ce n'était pas ce qui était perdu
mais j'en viens au sujet principal de
cette conférence de cette présentation
c'est le rider 2.0 alors recteur 2.0
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui avec le
budget à caen mais une vidéo sur
facebook instagram
moi le premier on va regarder combien de
bureaux à faire combien de partage bien
mais un commentaire calé communauté on
arrive à rattraper à mener autour ça
c'était différent de quand j'ai commencé
doucement et ryder 2.0 pourquoi dans le
sens plus évolution du rider 2 à 10 ans
il ya dix ans comment ça se passait
quand j'ai commencé on pratique et bmx
on était dans un relâchement parking
entre copains il y en a qui faisait les
compétitions gagner d'argent avec ça
certains faisaient des démonstrations
s'arrêter là aujourd'hui on a
différentes compétences moi je parle et
qu'on cap
j'ai fait des études en dd2 commercial à
roanne a limité et je savais pas
possible donc on m'a dit voilà tu as la
fin de ton diplôme tu peux être
commercial et commerciale pour vendre
quoi proposer pour qu'elle marche je me
posais pour une entreprise que je
connais pas ou avec qui j'ai pas
d'affinités je savais pas trop vraiment
pas peur qu'est ce que je peux vendre
des pièces de belux
le marché est un peu saturé c'était un
peu compliqué sachant que j'allais pas
des connaissances de en matériel
vraiment apprendre parler de vélo
et puis je me suis dit on m'a proposé de
faire une démonstration un jour de me
rémunérer pour faire une démonstration
comme bella - élaborer et du peu de
sujets je vais ensuite commercialisées
de vendre ses prestations la différence
d'organisateurs d'événements donc book
du bar la compétence commerciale
démarchage téléphonique ou par mail
station
ensuite je suis dit voilà aujourd'hui
elle domaine du web domaine internet
du coup j'ai fait une licence en
commerce pour créer un site web autour
de mon vélo autour de mes prestations
d'élite qu'est ce qui s'est passé du
coup j'ai fait mes collègues qui
apprenait à faire du codage tout ça pour
mettre un site en place pour avoir une
bonne note à l'école ou à côté de ça
j'ai essayé de développer un maximum on
s'y prend référencement en ajoutant les
données que j'ai eues en démarchage
téléphonique pour réussir à vendre un
maximum de prestations à la fin de cette
licence donc j'étais en normandie pour
la paix
on me propose pas j'ai fait en un projet
tutoré pour organiser un événement le
but en fait pour moi c'est en dehors du
fait de promouvoir moi mon image et de
mettre en avant que c'est surtout
promouvoir mon sport qui en parlent peu
médiatisé au monde ce que j'ai fait ces
gens raisonnent un événement je vais
faire une petite démonstration qui
tapissent a pris l'ampleur des
injections tour du monde connu ça
rappelait les sponsors saranais
d'engouement j'ai organisé cette
compétition pendant quatre ans les une
célèbre marque de boisson énergisante
qui à négative et que cet événement qui
a vu des millions de vues sur la toile
donc j'ai vraiment réussi à avoir la
compétence en plus organisateur de la
demande en puces de webmasters et de
commercial ensuite comme je vous disais
sur les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui tout
ce qu'on fait est assez important c'est
à dire que je vais aujourd'hui chez lui
le déclic je vais dire là je suis belle
présentation pour essayer de fidéliser
une certaine communauté qui va me sur
moi en dehors d'une certaine
reconnaissance je suis content qu'il y
ait des gens qui nous suivent
je prends qu'un quai des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui suivent les
actualités des milliers de personnes qui
qui la gêne et mes commentaires
mais les statuts peu importe surtout
j'ai beaucoup message de jeunes riders
22 jeunes pas encore à leur demande
comment je peux faire quand m rob ellis
capello choisir comment faire et du coup
c'est ça vraiment le le but de chercher
avec tout cet ep situation aux antilles
sport c'est réussir à créer l'engouement
créé des nouveaux sportifs
je reviendrai là dessus un petit peu
plus tard
dernier point pour un site web pour
m'étais design encore plus fou ça il
faut mettre de la vidéo m de la photo du
coup qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
regardé sur internet et tutoriels je me
suis expert professionnel mais je
maîtrise assez bien photoshop est
certaine
certains outils montage vidéo donc en
plus de ça j'ai certaines connaissances
en audiovisuel
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui en revenir
aux raiders 2.0 oui il est autour du
capital
oui il a une certaine connaissance des
médias sociaux pour développer un peu la
communication mais en plus de ça on a en
partant de vue staff un petit vélo on a
une multitude de connaissances
alors pour finir pourquoi je suis ici
aujourd'hui parce que tout simplement on
m'a contacté en disant qu'elle une
meilleure mais j'ai entendu parler de
ces 1 re année il y en a peut-être pas
renié vous qu'il ait une ps2 non si j'ai
vu ça s'est passé sur facebook j'ai vu
une figure du sur facebook h début à un
événement sur instagram et j'ai vu
quelque chose
et effectivement au plus personne ne
connaît ce via les réseaux sociaux
si j'étais pas du tout actif sur ces
réseaux là alors certes j'aurais
toujours détenus
j'aurai toujours le niveau que j'ai
actuellement mais je n'arriverai pas à
médiatiser le sport et si je pense que
tous les riders travail dans leurs
preuves ne développe pas un peu cet
aspect communautaire n'ose pas ça risque
de chacun va être fort dans son coin il
va y avoir plein de coups rider
dispatchés dans toute la france mais les
nouveaux les jeunes qui veulent se
mettre un sport
qui est très beau j'apprécie c'est très
compliqué pour eux d'avoir ne serait-ce
que des vidéos des photos comment faire
pour commencer
donc je voudrais conclure mais dessus
c'est on a besoin en fait les riders 2.0
dont je fais partie et des riders plus
placement
les riders précise ont dépassé leurs
huit pour chercher à oublier toute la
partie communauté la partie gros dos
toute la partie abonnés qui a derrière
ils vont juste cherché à repousser les
limites repoussées l'étudiant est ferme
et développer notre sport développé la
difficulté de 2 par an moi de mon côté
certes j'aurais moins niveau que ces
personnes là mais je vais m'occuper de
tout ce qui est la partie communication
toute la partie médiatisation pour vince
corner
il faut la faire la différence entre
repousser cette limite et la façon dont
on les partage il faut pas faire que
partager vos belles il faut aussi
repousser les limites de notre très beau
sport et je vais finir comme j'ai
commencé c'est-à-dire en freestyle hop
sous vos applaudissements
[Applaudissements]